buenas tardes yo soy manolo veterinario
cirujano y vengo a hablar de comida cómo
es que vengo a hablar de comida pues
hace un año perdió una apuesta una
comida con la organizadora del evento
una profesora de derecho y me ha pedido
que la lleve a comer a amarte si amarte
en eso sí que tengo culpa porque siempre
he presumido que los veterinarios
seríamos los mejores compañeros para un
viaje a marte sabemos de medicina
sabemos arreglar cosas sabemos coser
es carillas manejar un respirador y
además sabemos de comida así que ha
elegido marte y por si fuera poco se
trae a una amiga profesora de tecnología
de los alimentos espero que no descubran
que suspendí esta asignatura en la
carrera
he buscado en internet y no he
encontrado ningún menú de moda con
con un menú de degustación con ningún
restaurante de moda con ningún menú de
degustación en marte así que no me va a
quedar más remedio que cocinar yo y
aunque lo hago a menudo no hago nada
especialmente sorprendente vamos a
empezar por la bebida yo creo que con un
vinito blanco para los entrantes y con
un magnum de mencía del bierzo como ya
he dicho mi compañero para la comida
pues me podría me podría arreglar voy a
decir que los metan en la nave y me los
llevo que cuanto pesan
la que calculó yo creo que cuatro kilos
entre las dos botellas pero sólo me pegó
lo de dentro de las botellas luego las
las regaló ya haya cuatro kilos a millón
y medio de euros el kilo de equipaje
extra marte 6 millones de euros 6
millones de euros pues no se va a
arreglar llevar vino a la comida
entonces que bebemos
los chicos de la nasa han hecho un
trabajo fantástico es reciclar reciclar
agua se recicla más del 95%
espero que no se me escape hablar del
tema durante la comida porque el agua
que nos estamos bebiendo ya ha pasado
tres o cuatro veces por toda la
tripulación antes de la comida no debo
entrar en detalles
bueno plantar vida es hacer la vendimia
vino en vino en marte imposible y
cerveza que necesito para hacer cerveza
agua tenemos cereales vamos a llevar y
además vamos a plantar en nuestros
invernaderos
levadura tenemos para hacer pan con poco
más hace un siglo se fundaron algunas
cerveceras
bueno además para hacer cerveza no se
utiliza demasiado tiempo si lo
comparamos con el vino y se queda un
poco rara decimos que es cerveza de
autor y listo yo creo que la bebida la
tenemos seleccionada vamos a pasar a la
comida que necesitamos para agradar a
alguien en una comida buena parte de la
compañía que ya tengo solucionada con un
veterinario y las espectaculares vistas
de marte me tengo que concentrar en la
comida en sí misma bien con unas
materias primas exclusivas o bien con un
proceso de elaboración trabajoso y
sofisticado ahora que tenemos
estas cosas voy a empezar con la con la
comida
está claro que a millón y medio de euros
el kilo no me voy a poder traer ningún
capricho tengo que utilizar cosas de
producción local en marte
desde el principio cultivaremos
vegetales en invernadero ya tenemos una
gran experiencia en cultivos
hidropónicos y tenemos ya disponibles
lechugas tomates cebollas zanahorias
pimientos alubias rábanos patatas bueno
hasta la cebada que necesito para hacer
cerveza y la oferta sigue aumentando
sigue aumentando mucho y se llama
transgénico en marte no vamos a tener
los problemas ambientales ni los
peligros que tenemos en la tierra y cada
invernadero cada ecosistema que creemos
durante mucho tiempo va a ser
independiente
es posible que no tengamos plagas ni
enfermedades ni utilicemos herbicidas no
vamos a tardar mucho tiempo en ver la
pegatina de ecológico en los tomates
marcianos
yo hace tiempo que tengo la curiosidad
de probar el arroz dorado transgénico
rico en vitamina bueno con todo esto ya
me arreglaría para dar de comer a los
amigos vegetarianos de níjar pero yo
creo que mis comensales esperan algo más
de un veterinario que unas pizzas o unas
hamburguesas veganas
esperarán carne
yo creo que carne a la brasa una carne
roja a la brasa no se nos va a arreglar
sé que habéis leído que se pueden
cultivar miocitos para hacer filetes de
vaca para vegetarianos se morales pero
sólo hagan el pego en salchichas en
carne picada nada que ver con un
chuletón ni aunque utilicemos una bio
impresora 3d bueno quizás quizás el
hígado no me sirve nada de esto quizás
solo para el tema de conversación en la
mesa lo puedo llevar al extremo de decir
que voy a cultivar un trozo de mi
músculo para comer seguro que eso tiene
implicaciones legales y de seguridad
alimentaria que me van a permitir
discutir con mis invitadas
bueno empecemos por algo más realista
por algo más pequeño insectos
he encontrado una página web que dice
gusanos de la harina con frutos secos
producto
perfecto para la iniciación pero frutos
secos tampoco voy a tener en marte
insectos me llevo hay millones parece
que nos vamos a llevar abejas desde el
primer momento a los invernaderos pero
me dan pena como me voy a comer a la
abeja maya' no abejas sólo para miel
abejas prohibidas si al final yo creo
que voy a entender a los vegetarianos
y saltando algo un poquito más grande en
la facultad se crían unos mini camarones
y si los dejo crecer en medina del campo
crían langostinos
no quiero comparar medina del campo con
marte pero ejemplo creo que si le siento
me prepararía en una pecera para llevar
a marte y poderlos producir allí
langostinos de medina del campo en
martes así que va a ser una sorpresa
el siguiente paso lógico sería criar
peces pero no no tengo nada claro tienen
un buen coeficiente de transformación
están ricos pero nos seguimos pescando
hay algo que falla tengo que estudiar
más sobre el tema con los
a veces en suspenso deberíamos de pensar
en anfibios y reptiles a mí de pequeño
me gustaban las ancas de rana ya
últimamente no no se ven quizá pudiera
hacer el esfuerzo de crear unas pocas en
los invernaderos para la comida
y llegados a este punto no puedo menos
que acordarme de miguel delibes y de una
carne es suave y de mejor gusto que la
del conejo la de rata
estoy convencido de que si colonizamos
marte habrá ratas de hecho ya hay ratas
en la estación internacional
me dejarían alguna rata vieja de un
experimento que les sobrará para la
comida bueno me parece que con el perfil
de mis comensales no va a ser lo más
adecuado
y que me queda
ave que vuela a la cazuela dice un dicho
popular y además nos darían huevos
quizás las aves no sean una primera
opción cuando vamos a marte pero más
adelante
puede ser
el resto los animales mamíferos
mamíferos en marte va a ser complicado
creo que no se nos va a arreglar poder
consumir mamíferos en este momento en
marte
bueno y llega el momento de la verdad
que les pongo para comer
voy a empezar con los insectos
tengo grillos tengo gusanos tengo
hormigas
podría mezclarlos con otros alimentos y
podría poner los grillos con arroz poner
las hormigas en la ensalada dan un punto
cítrico que queda muy muy bien
pero si no les gusta me cargo me cargo
gran parte de la comida y no estoy para
tirar nada creo que los voy a poner como
entremeses y por separado
los grillos
he pensado ponerlos en tempura había
pensado ponerlos solo fritos
caramelizados o incluso en un caldito
pero creo que en tempura les van a
gustar no es lo más valiente pero pero
es una buena solución las hormigas
las voy a poner a la plancha y cultiva
duras hormigas culonas colombianas que
quedan muy bien así y por si lo leéis en
internet no es cierto que sean
afrodisíacas hay muchos mitos en este
sentido sobre la comida
las larvas los gusanos los voy a poner
unas tostas o si no nos agrada la
textura de esa manera se compensa con la
del pan la del pan duro
y de postre
después te encontrado un no fácil de
hacer y que además resulta exótico para
un paladar europeo
y está rico
en el lado de alubia
bueno ya os contaré cómo me va la comida
espero que no me den plantón no en
cualquier caso lo que sí voy a valorar
cada vez más es el trabajo en cocina
me están empezando a parecer baratos los
menús de degustación en los
y restaurantes con estrellas michelín
buen apetito
[Aplausos]